that's how you know I'm a good husband
I've retired any interest in being good
at sex she can trust me okay it's like
your husband's going to the strip club
yeah but he he bowls a 300. oh oh
[__] zero rizz oh he's good yeah he's
good yes
your only race is like bowling yeah
jokes yeah I often find myself with
fingers and holes and let me tell you
there's no split you're gonna do that's
harder than a 710 okay yeah here's your
money back oh you're good at bowling
here so sorry
um listen I made 10K tonight I'm gonna
give you one
I also laugh when we go bowling because
we actually try to be good and not one
person around us cares about being good
everyone else is just drunk as [__]
purling balls down Lanes hitting three
pins and going man I can't get 10.